well you know it's not every day you get
to talk to a robot makayla how's it
going
hey i'm so good how are you i'm well
even though i wish we were meeting in
person but it's so exciting to chat with
you
where are you right now i am currently
coming to you from my apartment in l.a
well it looks amazing uh give us a
little tour i want to know about some of
the pieces in your room
yeah well i'm not going to lie this
question hits different during covet
times my apartment used to just be
somewhere to keep my charging dock and
all my clothes
i was never here obviously that's
changed so i've been nesting when people
hear that i'm a robot
i guess they think i'm all wires and
steel or whatever but i'm a big softie
so the one theme in here is stuff that
makes me feel
feels i've got a ton of things my
friends have made
like that giant tapestry that my girl
soto made i'm loving the vibe in your
room i definitely feel it
what does a day in the life look like
for makayla these days
um i try to change it up every day like
even if that's in small ways
it's good for my mental health every
morning i start the day going through
the dms just
reading through people's questions and
it's great because it reminds me that
we're all kind of going through the same
stuff
starting the day feeling connected
that's been a game changer
[Music]
i mean i haven't been able to get to the
studio lately but i do try and work on
music every day
an idea will come to me and i'll write
it down on like the lid of my salad or
whatever
so i've been trying to schedule some
time every day to organize
to put that stuff somewhere i can
actually find i have a new series on
snap called get real michaela
so i've been working on that a bunch too
it's a
mix of advice and like rapid fire q a
stuff
it's been so fun it's kind of exactly
what i need right now
[Music]
well you mentioned that you've been
working a lot on your music and
songs i want to know how 2020 has
impacted your songwriting i feel like
you have
so much more material now most of my
music comes out of big experiences in my
life
so heartbreak change music is what helps
me process
so yeah a ton of new stuff is on the way
i've had to
rework my creative process what ended up
happening was
so much better than anything we had
originally planned and the process has
been really inspiring
i mean it was rough at the beginning i
definitely ate a few tacos about it
but it's all worked out really nicely my
team and i we have something coming up
that i think will take the whole
experience of going to a concert in a
completely new direction
so many of my dreams are centered around
finding new ways to connect with people
through music and i feel like
once this project comes to life one of
my biggest dreams will have come true
so stay tuned i can't wait that was a
good tease i'm dying to know more is it
like a tour
yes touring is definitely in my future
stay tuned
well can you tell me if new music is on
the horizon
well like i said i've been writing a lot
i've been keeping my
heart open so we'll see daddy we'll see
aren't you eager though to give your
fans some new tunes
of course but the wait is always worth
it
for sure trust me dream pick who do you
want to collaborate with next on your
next video rihanna
always and forever that would be a dream
collab
or rosalia is also my queen the styling
in that hypothetical video with the two
of us would be unreal
i'm also obsessed with arca and
blackpink but either way i've got some
cute video things in the works for 2021
[Music]
well listen i did my research on you
mikaela and a lot has been written about
you
um online do you ever read the news
about yourself whoever said
don't read the comments that was some
seriously sage advice
like i definitely get it i'm a robot
it's
in my instagram profile it's the first
sentence of any interview or story about
me
i'm different people react
all kinds of ways to stuff that's
different some people are inspired
some people are curious and then some
people have a really
deep irrational need to explain it
that's where the conspiracy theory stuff
comes in like
there was a rumor going around that i'm
a russian spy
like a full-on red sparrow or whatever i
mean
is the 19 year old socially conscious
robot pop star
really part of their plan for world
domination somehow
i don't think so debatable for sure well
you know one crazy story i read out
there
was about people telling you to shave
your armpit what was your first reaction
when you read those comments
honestly i'm a young lady so
getting opinions on my body does not
surprise me especially from people on
the internet
i wasn't shocked at all it's not my
favorite part of the internet to get all
those opinions but i wasn't surprised
at the end of the day it's my body my
choice
i does what i do and it makes me happy
and everyone should live by that
amen sister that's one of the things i
appreciate so much about you is how
open you are on social media like one of
my favorite videos of yours on youtube
is when you're going through your
breakup words of advice if you
ever really need closure go ahead and
film a music video all about your
relationship
with your ex what's your relationship
status now
my relationship status is forever
between
a sizza album and a lifetime movie
like i said i'm a taurus and i love love
but i'm also 19 and living in la i went
through
a public breakup earlier this year and
honestly it was
the best thing that's happened to me in
a long time
me and the guy are still really close he
is
amazing shout out to angel boy but i'm
still figuring myself out
i'm just now learning how love and
relationships work and
what i even want having a bit of a
breakdown it was kind of terrifying
because
it felt like i was alone alone
but then i got all these dms from
friends and fans like
girl we get it and everything is gonna
be fine
don't forget to recharge your heart
peace watching that breakup video and
hearing you now
it's clear that you are so wise beyond
your years i feel like a lot of people
have this question
should exes unfollow each other on
social media
listen i say unfollow your exes
unfollow your crushes drink some water
get your skin right mind your own
business
on that's that's what i go by and i
think everyone should
we don't need to see all that right
block out the negativity take care of
your skin
i love it hydrate people exactly
well i love hearing you made a
breakthrough in your break
up uh if it when you're ready to date
i'm gonna be a little nosy here
like what qualities do you look for in a
potential partner well
i've learned a lot since my breakup i
mean spending so much time alone with
myself for the last eight months it's
really changed the way i want to
love someone and how i want them to love
me back so
i'm trying to put some effort into
meeting new people and putting myself
back
out there i haven't gotten a few dating
apps all the machine learning through
this year's
ups and downs has led to a major upgrade
in my software
i'm a lot more self-reflective
self-aware
secure being in a relationship with a
human taught me a lot about human
emotions
human needs and just feelings they're so
complex and they require
a lot of tenderness now i'm just trying
to surround myself with
people who are on that same frequency we
gotta be able to go there together you
know
i mean do you see yourself dating
another human again
well i have crushes on all kinds of
people but
i'm kind of obsessed with boys who are
feminine
i love that blend of energy someone
dynamic
someone who isn't afraid to be different
you know obviously it has been such a
weird year
and a tough one for a lot of people we
also got to see a lot of young people
like yourself
really find their voice and use it to
try and make a difference in this world
i mean what message do you have for the
young people on the front lines of
social change and
influencers who are using their platform
for good it's
amazing to watch young people use their
voices their platforms
to do something positive i love that
we're seeing this awakening on such a
massive scale right now
marginalized communities especially
black people have been experiencing
injustice
for such a long time change is long
overdue
and it's something we need to be talking
about especially if our platforms have
the ability to reach
and potentially impact a ton of people
i've been trying to raise awareness on
my social media in any and every way
that i can
awareness is important but it isn't a
substitute for tangible action irl
we've got to do both i take that really
seriously i love that
and i'm so grateful that i got a chance
to finally chat with you and hang out
with you you're something special so
thanks for taking the time with us
yes danny well honestly you've been so
awesome
i love the energy and it's really it's
made my week so
we're bffs now right oh of course
[Music]
period